so let's take a look at the code for the
set announcement servlet you'll need to
have imported the memcache service and
the memcache service factory obviously
import all the things you need for HTTP
servlet and you'll have to import the
conference and the constants the set
announcement servlet extends httpservlet
and then basically we write the logic to
find out the conferences that are nearly
sold out so this is just a query so we
do the offi load we're loading entities
of kind conference we're filtering first
on seats available less than five but
there's no point telling us about
conferences that have no seats left at
all so obviously we need to filter on
seats available it's at least one ie
which is greater than zip greater than
zero then we create an array and
basically just add each of the
conference names to the array and then
if we do have some conferences we're
going to build a string that we're going
to use as the announcement we get the
announcement key which is stored in the
constants file obviously we have to get
the memcache service so we use memcache
service factory to get the memcache
service we use the announcement key and
we save our announcement in memcache we
set the status of the response to 204